just remind us all why mario pole has
been such a centerpiece in recent weeks
why it's so important yes i mean
according to putin's original plan mario
paul should have fallen within the first
few hours of this war on the 24th of
february and and here we are now in day
4748 and they're still fighting in the
middle of maripo it's important to put
him because it's part of his land bridge
that he would like to create between the
donbass and crimea if he doesn't have
mario paul then that land bridge is
always insecure it's also important
because it's the southern tip of his
encirclement that he wants to create now
between kharkiv further north and mario
paul so it it sort of anchors the
southern part of his offensive to try to
encircle this large part of the
ukrainian army in the donbass and there
have been reports that uh russian forces
may have used chemical agents those the
words of uh liz truster foreign
secretary clearly unconfirmed reports
what's the process from here over the
next couple of days to try and establish
if that that's true or not it's very
hard to establish um unless there are
quite a lot of victims it seems latest
reports in the last hour is that there
may be three people who were injured but
unless somebody somebody independent can
examine them it's very difficult we've
only got the word of the azov battalion
and they're not the most reliable of
units who are fighting in this war with
for the ukrainians most of the others
are um and i would be very cautious
president zelinski himself is being
cautious because he doesn't want to make
as huge anti-russian claims if they turn
out not to be true if it is the case
that chemicals have been used that would
be a huge step over another uh threshold
which the west would feel it has to
react to and is mario pole still
standing firm is it likely to fall
increasingly likely to fall in the
coming days well uh they're still
fighting at mario paul um it looks as if
the ukrainians have uh counter-attacked
in certain areas but ultimately the
ukrainians have got about four and a
half thousand troops we don't know how
many of them are still on their feet but
they had about fourteen four and a half
thousand the russians surround them with
that three times that number fourteen
thousand and the russians can bring up
more troops the nearest troops who could
help the ukrainians in mario paul are
probably about 60 miles away so given
that president putin has made it clear
he wants to take mario paul probably
before the 9th of may which is his great
victory parade and speeches then i think
the uh the next couple of weeks we'll
decide mario paul one way or the other
if we were to zoom out again and just uh
consider all of uh ukraine clearly a lot
of discussion about a renewed offensive
more broadly on the donbass region not
just mario pole
how much does the extra troops that
russia's moving there changed the
bargain there because of course they
were slow to make progress there as well
over the last couple they are i i mean
the fact is it's easier a country for
armoured vehicles and tanks but they've
left it until the spring which was very
soft the time to use armored vehicles in
ukraine is in the winter when it's cold
when frozen or in the summer when it's
hot and dusty and dry but the autumn of
the spring is exactly the wrong time to
try an armored uh thrust which the
russians must have thought they would
not have to do
and the ukrainians are very well dug in
in the donbass region they've been there
for since 2014 they've been there for
eight years so i think it may be a
monumental battle developing and
everybody knows that the the war will
depend on what now happens in the
donbass that this will either give
russia as it were a way out uh which
shows that they've grabbed a bit more
territory or it will push them back
again and it will create a stalemate and
leave putin in an even bigger mess than
he was in a week ago michael clark as
always thank you so much